Dental was listed as one of the causes of my cancer but I've never even had a cavity
so I was wondering what is going on with my mouth. The only dental work I've ever had
done is getting a couple baby teeth pulled as a child to make room for wisdom teeth extraction
by early 20s. I go to the dentist twice a year and the only slight problem I have now is some
sensitive areas where my gums have receded slightly but I have not, but they have not raised
any red flags and measure them yearly. So dental infections, some clinical dental infections are
a major cause or a major causative factor, let's say that to cancers. So you don't have to have
any symptoms, you don't have to have any root canal teeth, you don't have to have any problems.
So you do want to use that product that I recommended that biosighted product. You might only have to
do it for three months, it's a three month protocol and it might be done and that's it and that's
where we should test you and retester a cheek swung any time. So you don't have to have any dental
problems. In fact, 9 out of 10 people will say they go to the dentist, they don't have any issues
but their teeth actually can be a piece of the cause of the cancer.